[Musique]
ce chirac dans la première intervention
télévisée de la campagne officielle
vous avez proposé aux françaises et aux
français le renouveau dans la sécurité
s'agit-il là d'une de ces formules bien
balancé mais un peu creuses comme on en
utilise dans les campagnes électorales
ou bien cela recouvre-t-il une intention
est un projet politique précis c'est
évidemment un projet politique précis et
c'est également une exigence pour les
français vous sentez bien et je le vois
davantage chaque jour en parcourant nos
provinces de métropole ou d'outre-mer
que nos compatriotes veulent le
changement mais ils veulent également la
sécurité et le changement ou qu'est ce
que c'est c'est d'une part une autre
manière de gouverner donnant aux
françaises et aux français plus de
liberté plus de responsabilités mais
leur donnant aussi le sentiment que les
affaires de la france sont conduites
avec fermeté et puis c'est un objectif
une ambition celle de lutte est avant
tout contre le drame du chômage et pour
cela libérés les ans kling des
entreprises les travailleurs des
contraintes excessives qu'on fait peser
sur eux actuellement
oui monsieur chirac vous n'êtes pas le
seul à proposer le redressement
économique et le renouveau le candidat
du parti socialiste par exemple se
présente aussi comme un candidat de
renouveau oui et c'est dangereux
le renouveau que propose le candidat du
parti socialiste s'appuie sur des
propositions économiques bien ancienne
et que l'on connaît bien et qui ne
peuvent conduire je n'hésite pas à le
dire qu'à la physique dans la mesure où
il promet tout
mais où il ne prévoit aucun des moyens
nécessaires pour tenir ses promesses
et puis elles ne peuvent conduire sur le
plan politique l aventure car la
participation que son élection
impliquerait des communistes
vraiment nous fait craindre le pire au
niveau de nos libertés
au niveau de notre capacité à maîtriser
des affaires de notre pays
non ce n'est ni le renouveau ni surtout
la sécurité
mais je dois reconnaître que ce que l'on
nous propose carré guerre consistant à
continuer ce que nous faisons depuis des
années n'est pas non plus le renouveau
et n'est pas non plus la sécurité un
pays est qui qui a aujourd'hui un
million six cent mille chômeurs qui aura
d'après tous les experts si l'on ne
change pas de politique
près de deux millions et demi de
chômeurs dont près de 1 million et demi
de jeunes à la recherche d'un premier
emploi est un pays qui joue avec sa
stabilité et sa sécurité car on ne peut
pas imaginer que les hommes les femmes
et surtout les jeunes de notre pays
accepteront longtemps sans d'abord se
décourager sont peut-être un jour avoir
des sentiments ou des tentations de
révolte une situation où il ne
trouverait pas d'emploi où il serait
transformé en assistés et d'autre part
financièrement cela coûte très cher il
vaut toujours mieux payés des hommes à
travailler que de les payer ne rien
faire en un mot le renouveau c'est le
redressement économique et le
redressement social et vous vous êtes
longuement expliqué sur ces deux points
depuis deux mois
mais ce que vous entendez par sécurité
reste encore un petit peu fou dans
l'esprit des français et je souhaiterais
qu aujourd'hui vous nous en dire plus à
ce sujet bien la stabilité la sécurité
c'est d'abord la stabilité politique
pour un pays comme la france
qui dans les difficultés qui sont les
siennes ne peut pas si j'ose dire
s'offrir une crise politique pour que
cette stabilité soit assurée il faut que
le président qui demain sera élu puisse
disposer d'une majorité d'une majorité
pour soutenir à l'assemblée son
gouvernement
si je suis élu président j'aurai cette
majorité elle existe naturellement et je
l'accueillerait à bras ouverts je veux
dire de tout coeur qu'elle que quelqu'un
ait pu être sa position dans l'élection
présidentielle quelle qu'ait pu être son
origine au point de vue politique
pour moi il n'y aura pas de bien aimer
et de mal aimé dans la majorité mais
simplement des hommes et des femmes
décidés à participer à l'effort de
redressement de notre pays et cette
majorité enfin je l'élargir et car j
accueillerez sans aucun sectarisme
toutes celles et tous ceux en éliminant
personnes et avec les mêmes droits et
les mêmes devoirs qui voudront
s'associer à cet effort de redressement
enfin je le ferai dans un parlement qui
doit retrouver les droits qui sont les
siens en matière de contrôle en matière
d'initiative parlementaire
les droits que lui reconnaît la
constitution
mais quel âge de plus en plus lui
conteste abusivement le gouvernement
en somme vous prenez ainsi l'engagement
devant le pays d'assurer la stabilité
politique durant le prochain septennat
mais si vous le voulez bien faisons un
petit retour en arrière
vous savez que certains vous reprochent
de n'avoir pas été au cours des
dernières années dans la majorité
un facteur de stabilité oui c'est ainsi
qu'on crée les fausse réputation la
stabilité d'une majorité est uniquement
fonction de l'impulsion de l'esprit que
lui donne celui qui a la responsabilité
la plus importante c'est à dire le chef
de l'état
est ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
si je suis élu je ferai tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour restaurer par la
réconciliation l'unité nationale qui est
d'autant plus nécessaire aujourd'hui que
notre pays doit affronter de graves
difficultés notamment économiques
et c'est ainsi en particulier qu'il faut
mettre un terme à toute une série de
contentieux
je prendrai simplement un exemple mais
il n'est pas acceptable
aujourd'hui nos compatriotes rapatriés
d'algérie ou d'ailleurs soit encore déçu
traumatisée et un peu divisé par rapport
à la nation qu'il faut et j ai pris
j'en ai pris l'engagement que demain une
nouvelle loi règle définitivement leur
soeur mais il faut surtout qu une loi
définitive sans réserves totales
d'aministie permettent d'oublier ce qui
un temps nous a séparés mais ceux qui
maintenant c'est parti certes de notre
histoire mais pas de notre avenir
ce que vous dites là ne se chirac de la
sécurité concernent surtout la vie
politique
il aimait la vie politique est très
importante et ce comportement de
réconciliation et d'unité nationale est
essentiel vous savez je fais partie de
ceux qui dans notre histoire préfère et
de beaucoup henri iv à louis gaz la vie
politique est importante certes mais ce
que les français entendent par le mot de
sécurité le plus souvent dans leur vie
quotidienne c'est d'être un peu autre
chose c'est une préoccupation très
précises notamment celle de la sécurité
quelle est votre idée reçue la sécurité
et en particulier celle des personnes et
des biens mais pas assurés aujourd'hui
et c'est un drame pour beaucoup et
notamment pour les plus faibles
vous en savez quelque chose en tant que
maire de paris c'est vrai je n'ai pas la
responsabilité de sécurité à la partie à
l'état c'est à dire au préfet de police
là où je l'exercent modestement dans nos
square dans nos parcs
j'ai mis en place des systèmes
d'inspecteurs de sécurité qui ont
parfaitement réussi et qui prouvent
lorsqu'on a la volonté de le faire et
bien on peut assurer la sécurité
j'avais la démocratie est un régime
fragile
c'est un régime est essentielle dans la
mesure où il est le seul à permettre
d'exercer ses libertés aux citoyens mais
elle est toujours la démocratie menacée
et si elle veut survivre si elle veut
préserver les libertés
il faut qu'elles aient bien conscience
qu'elle doit être un régime d'autorité
c'est à dire un régime dont le chef le
gouvernement ne doit pas accepter que la
loi républicaine une fois voté par la
majorité et qui donc s'imposent soit
impunément bafouée et c'est pourquoi je
dis qu'il fallait avoir à la fois la
volonté mais aussi les moyens et que
l'un des premiers gestes de mon
gouvernement serait de déposer devant le
parlement un projet de loi programme
pour doter nos forces de police et de
gendarmerie des moyens en personnel et
en matériel nécessaire pour que ces
forces qui sont par ailleurs exemplaire
puisse exercer véritablement leur
éminente mission car rien n'est plus
important dans un état républicain que
d'assurer la sécurité des personnes et
des biens et le projet de loi dont vous
nous parler monsieur chirac et qui
seraient une de vos premières
initiatives ne vient il pas un peu tard
il y a déjà eu récemment à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat une discussion sur
une loi qui s'appelait sécurité et
liberté et vous n'avez pas voté cette
loi
oui on m'a déjà posé la question
simplement parce que ce dont nous avons
besoin aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas deux
textes supplémentaires est d'ailleurs
celui là pouvaient être dans d'autres
mains dangereux pour les libertés des
citoyens
mais ce dont nous avons besoin c'est
d'une volonté que chacun sache que s'il
enfreint la loi
il sera sanctionné avec justice mais
avec rigueur
et d'autre part nous avons besoin des
moyens c'est ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure au coeur des traits de sortir
maintenant peut-être un peu de cet
examen des projets des techniques pour
évoquer un point un peu personnel je
vous écoute puis quelques minutes vous
parlez beaucoup de sécurité de fermeté
d'autorité est ce que vous ne craignez
pas ainsi d'accentuer certains traits de
votre image dans l'opinion publique vous
savez que certains vous reprochent
d'être un homme autoritaire et ceux qui
ne vous aiment pas vraiment encore plus
loin oui ce n'est pas exact je suis à
nantes de concertation de dialogue
je les trouvais lorsque j'étais au
gouvernement qu'il soit de l'agriculture
par exemple ministre de l'agriculture où
je n'ai jamais pris une décision sans
qu'elle ait été concertés et en accord
avec tous les représentants des
agriculteurs
je le trouve en tant que maire de paris
en ayant développé largement les
structures de concertation je crois
beaucoup au dialogue il ya une perte de
temps concertation non pas du tout c'est
essentiel si l'on veut que la société
puisse évoluer et puis si l'on veut
bénéficier de l'imagination des uns et
des autres à s'enfermer dans la routine
c'est très important et bien c'est ainsi
que j'entends gouverner mais si je ne
suis pas un homme autoritaire
en revanche je considère que lorsque la
décision est prise elle doit être
appliquée et le cas échéant notamment
lorsque la sécurité est en jeu
elle doit l'être avec fermeté votre
conception de la démocratie telle que
vous nous l'exposé est un peu originale
pour vous la démocratie est un régime
d'autorité habituellement on associe
plutôt le mot démocratie aux mots de
liberté alors comment est ce que vous
concilier tout cela pour moi le seul
moyen de préserver les libertés c'est de
préserver la démocratie et donc il faut
que celle-ci ne soit mise en cause par
personne
les libertés qu est ce que c est là
aussi il y a beaucoup à dire la liberté
c'est d'abord les droits de l'homme et
je suis pour ma part préoccupé de voir à
quel point la france pays des droits de
l'homme
l'idée qui reste très forte chez tous
nos concitoyens et notamment dans le
coeur des jeunes de notre pays
cette conception alors que ces droits de
l'homme sont bafoués de plus en plus à
l'extérieur notamment n'anime plus la
politique de la france et sur le plan
intérieur nous voyons se développer à
nouveau des tentatives notamment
antisémites
on voit d'autre part également des
tentations de remettre en cause les
droits des émigrés bref il y a
aujourd'hui une remise en cause des
droits de l'homme il faut réagir
et là encore avec fermeté pour que ne se
développent pas dans notre pays
ces idées malsaines et dangereuses qui
sont en réalité plus ou moins des idées
racistes et puis il ya aussi
naturellement tout ce qui touche l'excès
et l'abus de la réglementation et qui
met en cause nos libertés il y à
l'inadaptation de notre organisation
administrative
c'est un des thèmes favoris la monsieur
chirac est ce que vous n'avez pas
tendance parfois à tirer sur le pianiste
les fonctionnaires sont chargés
actuellement de tous les péchés et après
tout vous êtes vous mêmes fonctionnaires
vous êtes un technocrate craie oui mais
rodez par des élections successives aux
réalités de la vie quotidienne
non les fonctionnaires sont en france
heureusement des gens éminents et ils
sont les premiers à souffrir de l'abus
de réglementation et aussi de
l'augmentation excessive du nombre de
fonctionnaires ce qui ne permet pas de
donner à ceux qui sont en place et qui
sont nécessaires à la fois la
considération le traitement le salaire
auquel il devrait avoir droit
regardez par exemple l'exemple des
instituteurs mais au delà je disais
l'organisation administrative
nous avons eu tort de rejeter 1969 la
réforme régionale que nous proposait le
général de gaulle
le moment est venu de la reprendre
aujourd'hui non pas pour donner la
dépendance politique naturellement aux
régions mais pour leur donner une
certaine dépendance économique social
culturel comme il faut développer les
moyens et aussi les pouvoirs des
municipalités des maires qui sont la
possibilité de développer la démocratie
du quotidien comme il faut développer je
le disais tout à l'heure
systématiquement la concertation et les
moyens de la concertation en somme vous
voulez rendre d'une certaine manière la
parole français mais dans le monde où
nous vivons pour prendre la parole et il
faut pouvoir utiliser les grands moyens
d'information la presse la télévision la
radio
est ce que vous n'avez pas le sentiment
que cet alourdissement de l'emprise de
l'état que vous dénoncez se fait sentir
aussi en matière d'information oui hélas
hélas c'est vrai que l'emprise de l'état
sur l'information dans notre pays est
tout à fait excessive et que pour cette
raison et aussi pour des raisons
d'évolutions techniques il faudra
prévoir beaucoup plus de liberté dans ce
domaine y compris en remettant en cause
probablement le monopole de
programmation plus de liberté ça me
paraît essentiel est naturellement cela
ne pourra et ne devra se faire qu'avec
l'accord je dis bien l'accord de la
presse écrite et notamment de la presse
régionale de la presse professionnelle
car si l'on devait développer la liberté
d'information au détriment de la presse
qu'à l'heure où on ferait une très
mauvaise action culturelle vous venez de
nous préciser ainsi monsieur chirac ce
que vous entendez par le renouveau dans
la sécurité
mais est ce qu'ils me manquent pas
l'essentiel finalement au moment où les
français vont choisir un président de la
république est ce que pour eux la
sécurité ce n'est pas avant tout la
confiance et la confiance dans les
engagements pris
oui la confiance j'ai fixé j'ai prévu
des engagements pris
les engagements j'ai fixé un calendrier
est bien comme je les ai toujours fait
en corrèze comme je lé fais à paris ses
engagements je les tiendrai pour
terminer si vous permettez monsieur
chirac je voudrais vous parler un peu
d'autres choses que de renouveau et de
sécurité j'ai entendu lundi soir comme
tous les français un certain nombre de
candidats monsieur giscard d'estaing
notamment qui avec un certain ton de
regret constaté qu'il était seul contre
9 dans cette campagne électorale qu'en
pensez vous vous avez lorsque j'étais
enfant et que nous jouions dans la cour
de récréation su par hasard je recevais
un petit coup je n'étais pas de ce qui
allait se plaindre aux surveillants mais
soyons sérieux
seul contre 9 qu'est ce que cela veut
dire je n'ai pas observé qu'aucun autre
candidat faisais ma campagne j'ai
également le sentiment d'être seuls
contre 9 tout simplement parce que je le
suis parce que chacun des candidats est
seul contre 9 dans la mesure où nous
sommes dix sept une situation qu'aucun
candidat ne put en réalité estimé être
le seul à l'avoir
je crois en réalité qu'il faut tout
simplement que chaque candidat puisse
s'exprimer librement
et puisse s'exprimer dans la sérénité et
sans polémiquer et pour ma part c'est ce
que je suis
[Musique]